[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUCHITRA HARI: My
name is Suchitra Hari.
I'm the Director of Engineering
for Shared Services at WP
Engine.
Shared services
is a team that is
focused on our internal
stakeholders at WP Engine.
A bulk of our
focus is on solving
for common problems that happen
across multiple different
product lines.
And the goal is to solve the
problems holistically instead
of one project at a time.
The idea is for our
developers to be
more in control
of when they ship
and what they ship and
standardize on common concerns
and, hence, help our
customers when online.
I do want to talk
about the team here.
It sounds as if this
is a very big team.
It's actually a very small team.
We have a product manager,
an engineering manager,
and a solid five-member
engineering team.
And so far, our adoption
rates have been excellent.
And its ever-growing.
Every few weeks, we're
onboarding a new engineering
team into our platform, a new
service or a new application
into our platform.
So far, we've released about
27 applications and services.
And as I speak, I think that
number is growing, growing.
The improvements to reliability
and our ability to deploy code
with an element of confidence--
it just means that
this is more time
back for our application
development team members
to build powerful
WordPress products that's
going to help our
customers when online.
I'm excited about
the possibilities.
And I think we could
be taking-- unleashing
the power of--
full power of Cloud
to a whole new
level at this point.
And that's just going to really
help our WP Engine customers
with online, ultimately.
It's a huge honor to accept this
award on behalf of WP Engine
and our amazing engineers in
the Catalyst software delivery
platform team.
This recognition comes at
a time where we've just
started reaping rewards of
investing in the software
delivery platform built on
top of Google's product suite.
Like I said, this
is an embodiment.
Our investment in the SDP is an
embodiment of our core value,
built for growth.
Being able to experience
lighter operational burden,
high availability, and an
ability to scale rapidly
is really important for WP
Engine's growth at this point.
So thank you.
Like I said, I'm super
excited about seeing
what unleashing the
full power of Cloud
is going to bring in for WP
Engine in the coming months
and years--
so super excited.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]